was geht ab leute ihr könnt euch gar
nicht vorstellen wie unfassbar vor ich
bin jetzt hier endlich zu sitzen und
endlich dieses video aufzunehmen
ich glaube ich habe selten so lange für
ein video geplant um zu brauchen dass es
statt auf jeden fall hat es echt extrem
lange gedauert ich versuche ich mal ganz
kurz und ganz schnell zu erklären was
ich heute vor hat und worum es gehen wir
und es habe ich mich dazu entschieden
etwas neues auszuprobieren oder na ja so
ganz neu ist es auch nicht diese mystery
boxen und dieser ganze quatsch ständig
in letzter zeit immer ausgepackt habe in
gewisser form sind das vielleicht auch
irgendwie restposten und so natürlich
und ihr kennt doch bestimmt so serien
aus amerika wo leute so ganze garagen
auf kaufen und das irgendwie zu geld
machen vielleicht auch so ein bisschen
könnte man das auch mit trödeltrupp in
deutschland ja gut lange rede kurzer
sinn ich bin auf eine seite gestoßen
die heißt restkosten irgendwas da gibt
es extrem viele angebote und anzeigen
von händlern aus ganz europa die
irgendwelche restposten verkaufen sei es
restposten laptops als restposten handys
als restposten konsolen sei es
restposten markenklamotten es gibt
eigentlich alle ich habe mich da so ein
bisschen umgeschaut und bin dann auf
dieses angebot gestoßen hier zum
beispiel sieht erstmal so aus werden
mindestabnahme zehn laptops für 50 euro
pro stück also insgesamt 500 euro dann
kriegst du zehn laptops von allen
möglichen marken apple acer was weiß ich
ich fand das direkt ultra geil wollte
den händler kontaktieren klick drauf
boom geht nicht musste ich erstmal
restposten anmelden für 80 euro alter
ich habe 80 euro ausgegeben dass ich den
händler überhaupt erstmal kontaktieren
kann die 80 euro habe ich bezahlt habe
dem händler geschrieben ja ich will die
den zehn laptops haben für 500 euro
er antwortet chicken house und listen
mit hunderttausenden laptops meinten sie
können sich die irgendwas raussuchen ich
gucke mir die listen an es hat mich so
ein bisschen sauer gemacht weil das war
total irre führen und in den listen da
gibt es gab es ganz viele verschiedene
laptops von 50 euro die billigsten fast
keiner bis zu über 1500 euro und ich
dachte mir um das kann teuer werden ich
hatte lange mit dem verhandelt und das
hat sich wirklich über wochen hingezogen
er hat mir dann irgendwann sehr guten
preis gemacht gute prozente gegeben und
ich habe mir irgendeine liste
rausgesucht von ihm da waren zehn
restposten laptops drin a und b ware das
heißt neuwertige ware und ware
laut ihm halt die von irgendwelchen
kunden einfach zurück gegangen ist weil
die nicht zufrieden waren und dann also
nichts kaputtes und habe zehn laptops
bestellt aus polen der typ saß in polen
für insgesamt 1380 euro und ich glaube
dass ich einen guten deal gemacht habe
ich weiß es nicht zu 100 prozent ich
habe die waren noch nicht gesehen aber
sie ist angekommen und die checken wir
jetzt mal ab ich möchte das ganze so ein
bisschen aufbereitet und dann verkaufen
und wir schauen mal wie für gewinnen wir
machen können das wird dann alles in
einem zweiten part gemacht ich schon
jetzt erstmal die ware an was habe ich
da bestellt kommt man mit st kein
problem für mich leute das paket geht
wirklich 32 kilo ist echt schwer aber
ich habe ja schon gesagt das war ein
kurzer film ist das hier gelandet ist
naja hier macht es auf ich freue mich
dass es auf jeden fall ganz schön gut
verpackt aber so soll es ja auch sein
ich meinen hier sind ja schon wertvolle
laptops drin
ok ich werde jetzt einfach alle erst mal
raus holen hier platzieren weil dann
können wir uns einen kleinen überblick
verschaffen und starten einfach mal hier
mit hier haben wir ein lenovo chromebook
ich glaube da sind mehrere dabei und den
chromebooks noch ein chromebook hier
haben wir ein kleineres chromebook
glaube hier haben wir ja steht nicht
drauf was ist es ja auch irgendwas von
lenovo und so geht das dann hier auch
weiter hier haben wir da noch einmal ein
anderes paket keine ahnung passieren ist
und das war's dann auch schon
bevor wir das eine oder andere jetzt mal
aufbauen ich will natürlich nicht alle
auflagen weil ist geil wenn die neu
verpackt sind obwohl das ist schon
besser wenn ich bei jedem mal reingucken
würde ich sagen das gute ist diese 1380
euro kann ich in diesem fall natürlich
auch steuerlich geltend machen und was
ihr so alles steuerlich geltend machen
könnt das erfahrt ihr es und da stelle
ich euch einfach mal zaster vor und
vielleicht kriegt ihr mit fast noch
einiges an geld zurück vor weihnachten
passiert kann man ja gut gebrauchen
zurzeit zwölf millionen menschen in
deutschland geben keine steuererklärung
ab obwohl eigentlich fast jeder um genau
zu sein
neun von zehn personen die eine
steuererklärung einreichen auch geld vom
staat zurückbekommen die meisten von
euch denken sicherlich das ist natürlich
auch mit jeder menge zeit verbunden ist
es sicher auch wenn man selber macht da
kommt jetzt aber
basta ins spiel nicht passt da sondern
zaster chst ihr könnt einfach auf den
ersten link ganz oben in der video
beschreibung klicken und euch dann
zuerst darzulegen dort gebt ihr dann
einfach ein paar daten wie name adresse
und steuer id an und werdet dann von
sister innerhalb von drei tagen ein
angebot zugeschickt bekommen theoretisch
kann man auch noch vier jahre
rückwirkend eine steuererklärung
einreichen so dass ihr im optimalfall
sogar vier steuererklärungen
gleichzeitig ein rechnen könnt und dann
vier rückerstattung auf einer bekommt
also halt nur wenn ihr wirklich auf die
letzten vier jahre keine steuererklärung
eingereicht haben wir gerade schon
gesagt das dauert dann ungefähr drei
tage und ihr erhaltet ein angebot von
kaster wie viel geld ihr womöglich
zurück bekommen könnte und dann kann
jeder für sich entscheiden ob die tops
steuerberater von kaster ihre
steuererklärung einreichen sollen oder
aus welchen gründen auch immer nicht
wobei da fallen mir eigentlich relativ
wenig ein jetzt wollt ihr sicher noch
wissen was das ganze kostet eigentlich
erst mal gar nix erst wenn ihr wirklich
geld zurückbekommt berechnet zaster eine
kleine gebühr die wird allerdings direkt
von diesem betrag abgezogen und erhaltet
eine fette summe auf euer konto bei den
meisten leuten sind es über tausend euro
pro jahr etwa 1000 euro sind eine menge
geld und da würde mir so einiges
einfallen was man damit machen kann ihr
habt also eigentlich ultra wenig
zeitaufwand und bekommt wenn es gut
läuft halt wie sie mal über 1000 euro
wieder warum nicht jagd auf jeden fall
just up erster link in der beschreibung
wie gesagt und wir machen jetzt weiter
ok willkommen zurück wir sind hier bei
diesem paket ich weiß gar nicht dass
hier sieht mir ein bisschen ja ich bin
einfach mal gespannt was jetzt drin ist
hier ist ein laptop was wissen das so
sieht das aus als es sieht wirklich neu
aus muss ich sagen da ist absolut gar
nichts dran ich glaube hier ist sogar
noch eine folie drauf nur wenn ich
ehrlich bin ich habe keine ahnung ob
dieses ding mehr als 138 euro wert ist
muss ich mal schauen das ist auf jeden
fall deutlich kleiner als die ganzen
laptops chromebooks die wir hier noch
liegen haben okay und einmal mittel hoch
fahren so sieht das aus ich hoffe ihr
könnt das auch gut sehen alter die sind
ja richtig richtig nass richtig feuchte
wer kein wunder wenn die
alles heile geblieben okay ich kann
jetzt in eine sprache einstellen kann
nicht hier mit meinem wlan verbinden ich
mache das einfach mal ganz kurz um zu
checken wieso die verfassung von dem
ding ist dadurch dass sie jetzt wirklich
drei tage in diesem post auto lagen sind
die halt haben diese feuchtigkeit
aufgenommen ein bisschen aber
funktioniert also in der zwischenzeit
mache ich einfach schon mal hier das
nächste und dann muss ich gleich mal den
wert der ganzen laptop ergoogeln was da
so zusammen kommen viele von euch habe
mich auch schon auf install gefragt was
denn eigentlich mit dem adventskalender
ist der geht ja eigentlich sollte er
schon gestern losgehen geht heute los
habe ich mir auf jeden fall echt coole
sachen überlegt es wird auf jeden fall
diesen dezember bei mir einiges zu
gewinnen im gesamtwert von über 7000
euro so ein krasses adventskalenders
wäsche hatte ich noch nie
vorsichtig das sieht jetzt natürlich
schon ein bisschen hochwertiger
ausgerückt mal leute richtig schön dünn
kann man jetzt hier auf klappen sagt
wunderschön also ich gehe schon davon
aus dass der sicherlich noch für 200
euro weggehen kann wobei ich natürlich
auch kein experte bin aber ich werde das
alles eher googeln und auch man fachmann
drüber gucken lassen und dann bin ich
einfach mal gespannt wie viel geld ich
für diese ganzen sachen bekommen kann
ich muss jetzt aufpassen dass ich nicht
total durcheinander kommen mit den
ganzen dingern hier hier haben war ja
das ist ja wieder ein anderes verfahren
aber erstmal die ganzen laptops
zusammenrechne auf was den wert wieder
kommen würde ich gerne schon mal sagen
ich habe mir gedacht heute kann man gut
damit rein starten dass ich unter allen
leuten wie das video hier schauen und
einen kommentar schreiben warum er
gerade einen neuen geilen lenovo laptop
gebrauchen können ein laptop wir
verlosen werde der ist komplett neu dass
es aber genau schreibt einfach kommentar
und sein argument vom kanal das ganz
wichtig aber es gibt in zukunft halt wie
gesagt jeden mit alle zwei tage hier in
wirklich geilen gewinnen okay das gerät
hier ist das lenovo 11,6 zoll chromebook
100e dann haben wir hier aber auch noch
fünf lenovo 14 zoll chromebook 14
ihr werdet gleich sehen ich habe für die
dinger 250 euro angesetzt ich habe ja
fünf stück davon 1 wird verloren hier
wird das für 264 euro verkaufen das
schon der günstigste preis nicht
gefunden habe also wir haben tatsächlich
nur lenovo laptops das wusste ich gar
nicht aber gut ist jetzt halt so ich
rechne jetzt mal den ganzen welt
zusammen und wir sehen uns dann gleich
wieder ich glaube aber das ist wirklich
gut aussieht
okay leute heftiger
ich habe jetzt alles mal eine tabelle
geschrieben habe das alles
zusammengerechnet ich habe von jedem
produkt den günstigsten wert genommen
wenn ich irgendwo gefunden habe also
immer das günstigste dh der mindestpreis
für alle diese sachen wer jetzt 2288
euro und das wird recht kompliziert weil
wir haben hier halt und produkte das ist
a ware dann haben wir aber auch b-ware
das hier zum beispiel war anscheinend b
ware aber ihr seht ja das ist ein top
zustand dieses ding hier zb ist 990 euro
wert aber das kann ich dafür natürlich
nicht verlangen ich bin ja einfach nur
so ein dummer youtuber der irgendwie so
einen restposten projekt mal einen den
euro 14 zoll chromebook geht es schon
weg da können wir die - 250 euro wieder
recht in das heißt wir haben es hier
2008 und 30 euro das sich dann aber auch
vom preis ab also von den 1100 euro die
investiert habe deshalb verlost wird
dann legen wir dabei circa 1245 euro
glaube ich grob überschlagen
das heißt ich hätte einen gewinn von 793
euro würde da jetzt aber einfach weil
ich kein offizieller verkäufer bin und
die ware halt zum teil anscheinend ja
schon mal irgendwie zurückgeschickt
wurde nochmals 20 prozent abziehen also
mal 0,8 dann legen wir hier wenn ich
alles verkauft bekommen wir einen
vernünftigen preis vielleicht bei 634
euro gewinnen was ich ja gar nicht so
schlecht ist also mein ziel wird es sein
mit mindestens 500 euro gewinnen
rauszugehen übrigens die leute das ist
patsche
das kannst du hier auch als touch
verwenden das ist schon ne diese dinge
werden neu für ja auf den meisten
webseiten sogar für 300 euro gehandelt
ich habe das bei mir immer mit 250 euro
angegeben also ich werde auch noch mal
einfach mal drüber schauen lassen der
muss mir das noch mal so ein bisschen
bestätigen alles ich bin auch ultra
gespannt auf eure kommentare ich weiß
unter euch gibt es auch mega viele
experten ihr könnt ja mal schreiben was
ihr so schätzen würde dann bin ich
einfach mal gespannt was das nächste
video so bringen wir was aber auch mega
cool ist ich habe eben noch restposten
smartphones aus spanien bestellt auch
über die seite das hatte sie geklaut
oder hatte ich auf jeden fall nicht so
starr wie mir den ganzen laptop wird wie
gesagt verlust wir gehen wir eben rüber
ich zeig euch die ganzen anderen sachen
genau das hier ist das einzige 14
chromebook was a ware ist deswegen wird
das auch verlost stell dich mal hier hin
das ist sehr sehr nice und hier könnt
ihr die ganzen anderen sachen sehen das
ist allerdings nur die hälfte die andere
hälfte ist noch beim 1
es kommt auf jeden fall noch einiges von
apple hinzu das wird auf jeden fall
wirklich will ja viele fragen jetzt
wahrscheinlich noch alex wo willst du
die sachen verkaufen weil ich bin mir
sicher der eine oder andere von euch
interessiert sich auch dafür in erster
linie versucht das über ebay und amazon
zu verkaufen ich bin nämlich sowieso so
nebenbei so ein bisschen auf amazon
aktiv und kann darauf sachen verkaufen
es sei denn viele von euch komme es auf
mich zu und wollen so ein gerät haben
ich will auf jeden fall niemanden
abziehen und wirklich nur ein absolut
fairen preis dafür nehmen wir müssen
aber auch verstehen dass ich jetzt nicht
für jedes geräten 138 euro oder so
verlangen kann einfach weil ich auch
wenn meine zeitaufwand damit hatte und
irgendwie muss dieses projekt ja auch
sinn ergeben ich habe euch in die video
beschreibung neben zaster meinen link
von der instagram seite gepackt darüber
werden die dann verkauft wenn ihr
interesse daran habt schreibt dort
einfach mal eine nachricht hin und ich
werde in den nächsten tagen dann die
sachen posten und auch wie viel geld
dafür gerne haben würde das war es erst
mit dem ersten teil ich habe mega bock
und mit sehr gehypt auf die weiteren
platz alles mögliche werden wir noch
bestellen und ich hoffe ihr auch
abonniert super gerne den kanal sechster
ab und wir sind uns übermorgen wieder
auszeichnen das hier ist übrigens die
ganze ware jetzt noch einmal im
überblick neuen laptops führen zusammen
1250 euro
ich bin super gespannt was wir da
rausholen können